here's what would happen if you were  stuck inside a grocery store for the  rest of your life  the first thing you'd need to focus on  would be preserving any food that would  go bad quickly you'd need to cure all  the meat in the store and try to dry the  fruits and veggies doing this would help  the food last for months instead of days  next you'd need to figure out a  sustainable food source start figuring  out how to become a gardener and plant  some seeds for fruits and vegetables to  grow in the coming weeks and months  you'd also need to figure out how to  reuse any rain water you could capture  as your running water won't last forever  and why are you doing all this well  maybe there's a zombie apocalypse  outside the store  you'd be able to survive here for an  incredibly long time the average  supermarket is said to have enough  supplies to keep a human alive for 55  years so you better get comfortable so